seven seven oh
that's right Boomers a couple times
Patti LaBelle rushed off stage mid
concert she and her fans were forced to
evacuate the venue due to a bomb threat
I give 10 000 every time I go on that
stage you will never get a sorry show
from me you're going to always get the
top of my ability it all went down on
Saturday during Paddy's Milwaukee show
at the Riverside Theater in a video
shared to Twitter the 78 year old
singers having a heart-to-heart with
fans after receiving flowers
770
2x8 units
moments later her security runs on stage
seemingly letting her know about the
incident before excluding Patty away
immediately after you can hear the
commotion from the crowd
to reports the Milwaukee Police provided
a statement saying the building was
quote safely evacuated law enforcement
shared an update later that evening
adding that no bombs were detected at
the venue and there's no threat to the
public at this time
ET has reached out to Patti LaBelle's
Reps for common meanwhile organizers
from the Riverside Theater shared a
statement informing fans that they are
working with Patty to reschedule the
show what if your fans meant to you who
come and see you and when you're able to
see those fans in person again it's the
best feeling ever I am I'm blessed to
have an audience who will buy Patti
LaBelle ticket and just love on the show
their cry they laugh
they meet new friends and my shows and
sometimes you would look at an audience
it's half white and half black but
they're all together and they end up
holding hands it's like
it's like a gumbo my I feel like I'm a
part of a gumbo and I bring it all
together you're the room yeah I'm the
room right
[Music]